notre dossier ce soir pour vraiment sur
l'impact des taux sur vos finances même
si la banque a pas augmenté son taux
directeur aujourd'hui elles veulent eux
aussi ce taux là probablement plusieurs
reprises cette année et marie-claude
maureille à des taux d'intérêt plus
élevés qui vont profiter à certains
secteurs en bourse c'est une bonne
nouvelle en général pour les émissions
financières les compagnies d'assurance
et les gestionnaires de patrimoine vont
dégager de meilleurs rendements sur
leurs placements donc c'est bon pour
elles les banques de leur côté vont
profiter de prêt plus payant à condition
bien sûr que les taux à long terme ce
qu'elle reçoive des emprunteurs soient
élevés alors que les taux à court terme
ce qu'elles paient aux déposants reste
relativement bas si c'est les ses marges
sur taux d'intérêt augmente réellement
comme ça devrait normalement être le cas
ça va se refléter dans l'épreuve dans
les profits ou au cours des prochains
mois par contre le marché s'y attend un
peu comme nous l'expliqué l'économiste
dominique lapointe
qu'est ce que le marché a déjà anticipé
en a vu depuis quand même certains mois
les institutions financières ont bien
performé à la bourse donc c'est à voir
est ce que les rendements vont
satisfaire les marchés ce qu'on peut
même dépasser les attentes ça restait
certes aimer ce qu'on remarque en
général dans cette phase du cycle c'est
important pour les éditions financière
autant au point du rendement que dans la
profitabilité
al'inverse marie-claude la hausse des
taux va rendre certains titres
probablement moins attrayant on risque
de voir des réévaluations dans le
secteur technologique qui a eu vraiment
une explosion des valeurs depuis le
début de la pandémie on voit déjà une
correction depuis le début de l'année le
nasdaq a perdu très et demi pour cent et
on peut s'attendre à ce que ça se
poursuive parce que quand on investit
dans des entreprises technologiques
on paie pour la croissance future on est
prêt à attendre plus longtemps quand les
taux sont au plancher parce que 1 $ dans
10 ans vaut plus cher quand les taux
sont très bas que si on peut obtenir 5
ou 10% avec des placements sans risque
donc on risque de voir ce phénomène au
cours des prochains mois la trompe
écouter le gestionnaire de portefeuille
jean paul giacometti
et 50 cent fois les profits ou même les
fois ces mêmes points de profits avec
juste plusieurs fois les ventes selon
sont touchés plus fortement penser des
mauvaises compagnies points qui vont
arrêter pour vous donner un exemple les
compagnies comme microsoft de 2000 à
2010 les profits ont monté sans arrêt
mais l'action a rien fait donc c'est
juste les gens ont payé de moins en
moins pour des profits futurs et
l'action ne monte pas même si la
compagnie vos gains
ok très intéressant agréable de revoir
jean paul giacometti qu'en est il
maintenant du secteur de la consommation
en fait quand l'étau monde c'est parce
que l'économie va bien les consommateurs
sont au rendez vous alors tant que la
croissance s maintiendra ce sera bon
pour la consommation discrétionnaire des
vêtements les loisirs l'électronique les
meubles tout ça devrait en profiter à
court terme à long terme si la hausse
des taux par est bel et bien à ralentir
la croissance la consommation de base
devrait devenir plus intéressant donc
les produits que les consommateurs n'ont
pas le choix d'acheter on pense par
exemple à l'alimentation les produits
d'hygiène ce genre de produits qui sont
beaucoup moins cycliques un bon tour de
piste merci beaucoup marie claude je
vous en prie bonne soirée
[Musique]
en tout cas la montée des taux d'intérêt
aura un impact sur les rendements
obligataires a déjà un impact sur les
rendements obligataires c'est quoi les
faits sur le portefeuille des gens des
investisseurs l'effet peut être directe
et malheureusement pas nécessairement
positif ce qui inquiète bien des gens
qui nous écoutent des retraités entre
autres dont le portefeuille souvent est
constituée en bonne partie des
obligations parce qu'on veut réduire le
risque par exemple alors je vous
explique un peu comment ça se produit
l'enchaînement par exemple on a un taux
d'inflation qui est élevé en ce moment
on nous a prévenus qu'il y aura
plusieurs hausse du taux directeur ce
qui risque d'alimenter la hausse des
taux obligataires et c'est là où ça
touche votre portefeuille s'entraînent
une baise la valeur de l'obligation
parce que évidemment le prix et le
rendement des obligations fonctionne en
sens inverse exact je vous donne
l'exemple d'une obligation vous auriez
acheté et qui vous donne 2 % de taux
d'intérêts par année si les taux sont
bas sur les marchés votre obligation est
plus payant que le marché donc sa valeur
augmente mais quand les taux d'intérêt
au contraire remontent comme c'est le
cas en ce moment là votre obligation
devient moins payante que le marché et
sa valeur des sens et c'est la crainte
en ce moment avec la hausse du taux
directeur et des taux obligataires et
c'est une préoccupation parce que ça
fait un moment déjà que les titres
obligataires ne sont pas très payant je
vais vous montrer le bilan pour 2021
vraiment ça a été pénible j'ai un
exemple d'un fonds négociés en bourse de
plusieurs obligations du gouvernement
canadien rendement négatif de plus 3% un
autre fonds négociés en bourse
d'obligations à long terme presque 5% de
recul et pour les certificats de
placement garanti ça rapporte pas grand
chose quand vous déduisez une fois
l'inflation alors oui c'est une
préoccupation important est ce que ça
vaut encore la peine de détenir des
obligations quand on voit ça dans son
portefeuille c'est encore une raison
d'être évidemment les obligations ne
serait ce que pour le principe de
diversification et on a des données aux
états unis qui nous montre qu
historiquement bas finalement c'est
peut-être pas si mal que ça les
obligations en période de forte
inflation des données depuis à peu près
90 ans qui monte les bons du trésor
enfin en période de forte inflation
recul oui mais moins que les marchés
boursiers se le dise qu'on mise encore
sur les obligations cette année je vais
vous montrer les rendements qu'on nous
fait miroiter en ce moment c'est à peu
près 1% pour un certificat de placement
garanti d'un an 2 à 3% pour les
certificats de placement garanti de cinq
ans et pour les obligations du québec le
voyez les rendements sont pas très
intéressants alors oui il y en a
plusieurs qui réfléchissent à la con
l'allocation des actifs dans leur
portefeuille pour trait aussi très
intéressant merci merci aux yeux pour
voir nos émissions en entier rendez vous
sur la chaîne ici et redit
oh